hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one theme that comes up at several
points in plutarch's work on controlling
anger is that of tyranny and it'll come
up in several different ways we should
say first of all what does tyranny
actually mean because that that's a word
that gets thrown around quite a bit by
people in the present and it's it's used
in a somewhat different way in ancient
Greece than it tends to be used today
where there's some connection but
there's also some important differences
so a tyrant isn't just somebody who
happens to have power or tells you what
to do a tyranny was a particular bad
form of government in ancient Greece
where you had one person who somehow
took power they might have been a
demagogue they might have come in with
forces and conquered a play and they
establish themselves as the sole ruler
and actually Aristotle provides us with
a very nice way of distinguishing this
from a traditional monarchy the Tyrant
governs for their own benefit they are
primarily interested in holding power
and the things that it will get them and
they rule arbitrarily they don't govern
for the good of other people within the
society except for those who are willing
to be the Yes Men or the butt kissers
for the Tyra to tell them that what
they're doing is A-Okay and we see that
not only does Aristotle condemned
tyranny this is also a big problem for
Plato he thinks that the Tyrant is in
some respects the worst of all people
lacking self-control using the entire
Society essentially to benefit himself
rather than everybody else so in Pluto
Turk is likening anger to a tyrant
there's all of this background stuff
built into it for the audience that he's
writing to
and he tells us that anger is
overbearing and stubborn and altogether
difficult for anyone other than itself
to move and here's where the Tyranny
part comes in he says that it's like a
well fortified
tyranny and how so well we should pause
on that for a moment anger is like a
well-fortified tyranny it is difficult
to bodge you can fight against the the
Tyrant but the Tyrant is probably going
to win unless
it has as he says it must have its
Destroyer the one who is going to bring
down the tyranny in uh Greek it's uh uh
here we go
um kataluone the undoer the bringer down
to to nothing of the Tyranny so it has
to have its Destroyer as he says either
borns and genos or bread
literally in the same household as the
the Tyrant him or herself right so anger
if anger is a tyrant we need something
else that within that spectrum and it's
actually going to be something else
within the soul namely reason that we're
training up to take care of anger to
destroy the Tyrant to assassinate the
Tyrant perhaps we might even say and so
that's the first reference to tyranny
and then he's going to talk about
destroying tyranny once again
in a little bit further on as well so
he's going to tell us that destroying
anger you know like a tyrant within
ourselves otherwise it would Rule and it
would rule capriciously arbitrarily not
to our benefit but just being driven by
its own passion and he tells us that the
first way to a nice translation here
dethron or to destroy tempers you would
a tyrant is not to obey or to listen
when it starts giving us orders and the
Greek here is uh pathos thigh May pathos
I don't obey don't listen to it
is is to hear and who bakwane is to like
hear and obey so these are kind of
synonyms for each other when anger is
telling us what to do or literally
setting things up for us
so touching is to arrange to order and
it comes to be used for giving orders
and prostache in relation to something
so when anger is trying to boss us
around you could say and making us bossy
in the process then if we want to
Dethrone it we don't obey or listen and
you know it's kind of funny because you
could say well if you don't obey the
Tyrant then the Tyrant is going to use
his guards or his military forces
against you or he'll kill you with a
sword or whatever he's going to do put
you to the torture and yes when we're
dealing with political life you do have
to be worried about tyrants doing things
to you
but if you think about yourself why do
you let thumos anger temper why do you
let it boss you around why do you allow
it to tyrannize over you
Plutarch is saying we we actually
shouldn't do that
the next reference to tyrants has to do
with the as it's being translated here
the butcheries the word is actually
coming from the word for killing or
murder in this case
Mii fonias and so he says that you know
tyrants in their butcheries they show
certain qualities to us he says in The
Butchery is that tyrants engage in their
meanness or littleness of Soul their
micropsia right their smallness of Soul
the being focusing focused on on things
that don't really matter that much is
displayed in their cruelty in in the
ways that they behave and their
perverted State as he says in their
actions in the things that they they
actually do so you know tyrants show
themselves as being you could say Petty
would be another word for small soul and
messed up as we would say in the present
now this is what makes people kind of
dangerous when they get angry and so
he's going to generalize from this to
say in Weak souls in people who you know
aren't don't have their you might say
their their things together he says that
just as with the flesh a swelling
results from a blow so with the weakest
Souls the inclination to inflict a hurt
on somebody else
to injure them in some way to pain them
in some way in Greek
right to hurt somebody to make them feel
pain this inclination to hurt is what
produces the flare-up of anger or temper
of thumos in this case so tyrants
because they are messed up individuals
are very liable to get angry but anybody
else who's got a you know disordered
soul is likely to get angry as well so
you know he gives you some examples uh
most prone to anger are The Miser with
his Steward right so a miser is somebody
who wants to hoard wealth the steward is
the person who's in charge of the
household and The Miser gets angry with
them very easily the the Glutton with
his cook the Glutton is somebody who has
a weakness for the pleasures of food and
drink they get upset with their cook the
jealous man with his wife the conceited
man when he has been maligned and then
he quotes pindar saying the worst of all
are men who Court to eagerly ambition in
the town manifest is the pain that they
bring in like manner from the pain and
suffering of the Soul caused generally
by weakness there arises the Outburst of
passion and so you know we don't
necessarily need to be a political
tyrant in order to tyrannize over other
people we just need to have this kind of
you know weakness these trigger points
of the things that we really value even
though they're not that that important
and to be badly off in relation into
them this leads us to another
consideration where tyrants aren't
actually coming up in word but we can
think about the danger of ourselves
becoming tyrannical with other people so
uh Plutarch is going to say we actually
need to learn how to control our anger
with who with the people who are
vulnerable to us precisely because we
have power over them this exousia right
this this capacity to determine things
and because of the power that we have
the capacity others are not going to get
in our way when we're we're doing the
things that we shouldn't do getting
angry when people otherwise might oppose
or prevent us and
he says that under the influence of this
passion the the pathos of anger you will
screw up you will Air uh is is the Greek
there hamartia is
um the word for sin it's also the word
for error it's the word for screw up and
it there's a even blemish can be
hamarity as well so because of the
influence of The Passion of anger
unless we do something to stand in the
way of it we are going to allow it to
extend out there to people who are
vulnerable to us so he uh he actually
says here that we need to Encompass it
or you know gird it around
with a value or a virtue that of
gentleness proud taste is the word for
the quality of not getting angry or
directing one's anger properly sometimes
translated as mildness meekness
gentleness good temper so if we don't
Encompass the passion with that we're
likely to become tyrannical in our
expression of anger particularly in this
case towards those who are our servants
or even slaves those who are connected
to us and over whom we have power the
last thing that he says about this
that's very interesting is that we
should hold out against the please or
the criticisms of spouse and friends who
are saying oh you're being too easy on
these people you're not getting angry
when you ask me what's the matter with
you you're not a man right that would be
the sort of refrain and the worry there
is well you're going to spoil these
people and Plutarch is saying you know
that's not a a good thing to get into
you're allowing somebody else to talk
you into behaving like a tyrant to these
these poor people that are just trying
to make a living are just trying to get
by and so there's a lot of ways in which
we can allow anger itself to become a
tyrant or we ourselves can become
tyrannical the goal would be to destroy
it to bring it down to end that regime
and to replace it with something better
namely the virtue of proudes or good
temper gentleness mildness whatever it
is that we want to call it as a
substitute for anger's tyranny